you will recall that last week there was
a
fascinating little
between nicki minaj and joy reid in
which nicki minaj tweeted out a bizarre
story about her cousin's friend
in trinidad
having swollen testicles and impotent
because of the vaccine which of course
is silly there's no scientific evidence
that the vaccine causes swollen
testicles or impotence
and that is that is a very silly
contention
but then joy reid sounded off and she
went after nicki minaj and nicki minaj
said that she was going after her
because of a race and it was all very
entertaining
now let's assume for a second that the
person who tweeted this out was not a
famous rap artist
most famous for shaking her posterior
and being a democrat let's let's say for
a second that this has been a country
western star who had said
my cousin down in alabama
got swollen balls from the vaccine
do you think the white house would have
reached out
what do you think or do you think it
would have earned extraordinary mockery
from the white house
i i have a feeling i know which way this
would go
right if somebody on the right had said
something as bizarre and stupid as nicki
minaj the white house would have said
this is bizarre and stupid and
inexcusable because this person has
millions and millions of followers
instead
you get from the white house yeah we
called up nicki minaj we're trying to
talk to nicki minaj
okay the reason for that is not because
of our millions of followers because
again it depends on who's saying the
thing
the reason they are doing this is
because nicki minaj they believe is on
their political side of the aisle so
they will give her a lot more
credibility and they will try to talk
her into it and they will be sweet and
nice now here's the thing they should be
nice and they should be trying to talk
people into it regardless of your
political position as i've said a
thousand times i have individually on a
one-to-one level tried to talk probably
100 people into taking the vaccine and
i've been successful maybe 25 30 percent
of the time doesn't matter you still
have to talk to people on an individual
level the white house doesn't do that if
you're from florida go ahead and die
sucker and if you're nicki minaj we're
going to call you up and try and we're
going to try and we're going to spend an
hour explaining to you the data behind
vaccinations and ball swelling
here is uh here is jen saki doing this
it's unreal
we offered a call with nicki minaj and
one of our doctors to answer questions
she had about the safety and
effectiveness of the vaccine this is
pretty standard and something we do all
the time it was a very early stage call
at a staff level staff to staff
and we weren't even at the point of
discussing we're not even at the point
of discussing i should say at this point
um the mechanisms or the formats or
anything along those lines it was simply
an offer to have a conversation and
an early stage call
look how sweet they are to nicki minaj
how sweet they are to particular people
who are vaccine hesitant or promoting
overt vaccine misinformation like nicki
minaj did look how sweet they're being
however
if nicki minaj were a white guy in
florida who refused to take the vaccine
and then got sick and needed monoclonal
antibody treatment then well you know
equity suggests that we have to send
this dose to a place that doesn't need
it because there are no shortages
currently in any of these other states
as gensake overtly admitted this is just
about spite and it's about ire it's
about nastiness and it's about people
dying and they don't care
this administration is a bleep show it
is a highly political bleep show again
jared kushner was raked over the cold
for the suggestion that he was branching
out ventilators which by the way have
turned out to be one of the worst things
for covet but he was ripped up and down
for the suggestion that was never
verified that he was trashing out
ventilators by political preference of
states
that wasn't true he didn't do it
didn't matter he was ripped up and down
for it right he was a bad man the white
house does it openly
openly in front of the press
and everybody's like well you know
that's just the way it goes i mean
rhonda sands this is a pretty bad guy
meanwhile what is all of this really
driven by all of this is driven by a
desire to pin the policy failures of
this administration on the unvaccinated
the idea is we can never go back to
normal until we force everybody to do
what we want and here's the thing we can
you know how i know that i live in a
state that did
many states have done this many states
have this is particularly true for the
vaccinated if you are vaccinated this is
driving me up a damned wall if you're
vaccinated you're safe stop it
stop it everybody is yelling at the
unvaccinated and i understand if you're
unvaccinated and you have any sort of
pre-existing condition and if you don't
have a pre-existing condition your
chances of a side effect from the
vaccine if you are above the age of 18
are are significantly lower than your
chances of a side effect from the actual
covet itself the natural immunity you
get from covert is going to be more
durable than vaccine but
the chances of you getting super sick
from a vaccine are a lot lower than the
chances of you getting super sick from
covet
and that's the stat
now
i understand a lot of people being
peeved at the at the unvaccinated
particularly the unvaccinated who've not
already had covet if you're if you if
you already had covet and people are mad
at you i i don't know what to say those
people are idiots if you've already had
covet and the notion is you must get
vaccinated regardless of whether you
have antibodies or t-cell memory those
people are not following the science but
there's a joe biden is trying to drive
up ire at the unvaccinated let me just
say this to the vaccinated you're
vaccinated you're protected stop this
bull
seriously i know people who are like
double triple vacs have had the boosters
and they're still like i can't go
anywhere near anybody i can't i can't go
anywhere near anyone i can't you know
you have to test before we meet
stop it you're being paranoid at a
certain point somebody's gonna have to
dose you on the reality and the reality
is this disease does not kill a huge
number of people per thousand
not compared to smallpox
and which is a serious disease that
killed one-third of the population
it is more serious than the flu
once you have the vaccine it is
significantly less serious than the flu
this vaccine is a
why am i the only person who is telling
the vaccinated to stop whining you are
now protected i'm vaccinated my parents
are vaccinated i am not afraid for them
i'm not
and honest to god you know who else i am
not afraid for i'm not afraid for my
kids and the reason i'm not afraid for
my kids is because i'm looking at the
statistics
the media don't want you to look at the
stats they want to focus in on anecdotal
evidence every day in the media there's
an article about how
how kids are at significant risk kids
are going to die and then you wait for
them to cite stats
and there aren't any stats there's a
piece in the washington post that says
parenting a child under 12 in the age of
delta
it's like a fire alarm every day no it's
not i have three children under the age
of 12. you know what would happen if
somebody in their class got delta
nothing i'd send them to school the next
day because i'm not crazy
but you've driven everybody nuts the
media the bite administration they've
driven the vaccinated nuts
i may think it's nutty for a 65 year old
person not to get the vaccine in fact i
do think it's pretty nutty for a 65 year
old person not to get the vaccine if
they've not already had covet i think
that is bad risk assessment i think it
is similarly nutty maybe even more nutty
to once you have had the vaccine spend
the rest of your life hiding in a bubble
and demanding that the rest of the world
cater to you this is nuts
stop it just stop
coming i'm to read you from this
washington post article in a second
because it's just an incredible example
of how the media are garbage at this
they are garbage they've scared people
into unrational unreasoning
tyrant following position that's all
this is at this point because you can
get people keep saying when we get to go
back to normal are you vaccinated the
answer is now
and by the way if you're unvaccinated
you can go back to normal too you're
just gonna have to bear the consequences
of that because that's called freedom
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video